hands face space for most of us obeying
the official instructions to prevent the
spread of covid
has become a ritual if not quite second
nature
keep a gloves on clean the chair before
and after
every customer new guns uh we have
sanitizers we're
everything we're doing our best
basically to keep it
great thanks very much now that we're
allowed back into even
so-called non-essential shops antivirus
measures
which may be costly and dramatic are
proudly on show
but more than a year into the crisis we
should know by now what works
and pointless motions we're going
through just to make us feel better
oxford professor jennifer dowd
is one of the self-described nerdy girls
who've been examining the evidence
on their dear pandemic site
unfortunately i do agree with the term
hygiene theater in the sense that i
think a lot of this is about making us
feel safer you know small businesses
want customers to come back in and feel
safe and there's these are things they
can demonstrably
do but i think that the danger comes
when it you know it could be doing more
harm
than good
plexiglas screens obstructing air
circulation are one of their bet noir
but topping their hit list is obsessive
cleaning of
surfaces so called fomites where
infection
might possibly be found the the uscdc
has reviewed the data and changed their
guidance pretty recently
and their assessment of the data was
that even if you touched a contaminated
surface your chance of becoming infected
was
less than one in ten thousand um and
there's just a whole series of events
that would have to happen you know
someone very infectious
would have to sneeze or cough directly
onto a surface that you
touched you know very shortly thereafter
you would then have to get that
somehow into your nose or eyes and your
your mucous membranes in order to have
an
infection it's not the same as breathing
in all of those
tiny particles at the beginning of the
pandemic
we were encouraged to stay off public
transport for fear of spreading
contagion
now innovative ideas are being developed
to encourage people to
get back on the buses safely
as it's pumped through the nozzles the
fluid is aerosolized
to create a very fine fog which
spreads all the way through the vehicle
and this all happens
in the middle of the night this can
happen in the middle of night when the
bus is out of service
reassuring customers they're safe cost d
g bus company
in stoke on trent about 3 500 pounds per
bus
to install the v-stop sanitation system
after that it's just one pound fifty per
clean automatically with no staff
required
dng are giving priority to their route
serving hospitals
there are obvious applications for
enclosed environments
qatar has already been in touch with its
mass transit systems
for the world cup in general for the
rest of us
now that the infection rate is subsiding
here the best protection
is a healthy blast of fresh air adam
bolton
sky news